♪Four and three and
two and one, one
- Go for Abbi.
I am not a mom!
- Look what the cat dragged in.
- [Ilana] Oh my god.
- Ha! Ha! HA!
- I'm the hot girl at this bar.
Me! Me is!
- Yow!
- The only reason I pegged
you in the first place
is because Ilana's
grandmother died.
Training with Trey.
He's just been on me.
- Get him off.
- I would not get
him off! What?!
Totally at ease.
- Cool.
- [Abbi] You know
me from my ass,
better than you know
me from my face?
- Yep!
- Cause Abbi is kinda like
this undiscovered genius
with the ass of an angel.
Red team, you guys can come eat
my ass one at a f***ing time
- I'm your main squeeze?
- You're my favorite little
Jewie this side of St. Louie.
Oh. Hello.
Feel so alive right now!
I got you Bingo Bronson!
- Abbi, no!
- This is the men's room.
- Ah doy!
(energetic pop music)